this place
yes yes
what they say
yeah
the rotational choice
so so anyway this is uh David's second
talk and I guess he needs no
introductions yesterday
so um
we will use this zero distributions and
then please the convex relaxations that
they correspond to in order to um
to design algorithms for construction
problems
and uh in particular that that's
motivated by the unique games conjecture
um and the negative is a conjecture
about the following problem
okay
um
but I think it was designated
it's a promise problem that has a
parameter Epsilon and okay so how does
it work
so the input
consists of variables X1 after x n
and
[Music]
they are they take values these
Miserables are over and alphabet
consisting of numbers from one to K
foreign
we have a system of equations
you might think
and we have a system of equations in
these variables
and these equations are very uh very
simple
and these equations you know
you ask them to be satisfied yes
okay
and um
okay and
this uh this prop this instance this
input
uh yeah it depends on uh yes I J and C
Range Rover uh
I enjoy range of our uh one to n and C
ranges
can be any anything between uh
but it's yeah so so maybe one way to
visualize it is that
you know here you have the variables
then you have edges
and um
we've been within the variables and and
they are labeled by
numbers C indicating so that's a very
good encode C is C sub i j e w the same
for all yes yes yes
why is it yeah it doesn't depend on
I and J it depends on
the specific equation right yes yes this
is a different base of a different race
okay
[Laughter]
the
instance come to the promise and the
promise is that they exist a good
solution and the solution the solution
means here the x is a solution X that
satisfies
um
one minus Epsilon fraction of the
constraint
s
and your goal
is to find a solution
that satisfies
let's say 0.9 of the constraint
s and what the indication lecture says
is that this problem is simply hard
this is a conjunction
problem can be hard for every Epsilon
bigger than zero
and there's one aspect that I'm
been ignoring it's okay here they are
abroaded is sort of part of the input
um
so it means that you're considering
algorithms that should work for for okay
but um actually you're only interested
in in KL are not too large so it's okay
let's say it's less than one
so that's sort of an addition you can
think of it as an additional promise
on the instance and then the conjecture
says that even with this additional
promise it's still had to be hard to to
solve this problem so technically what
you just stated can't be true
why I mean if Epsilon is let's say one
then you know that you can't satisfy
anything no no but I mean you know
uh at least you may not have some reason
so maybe I mean okay if it doesn't say
that at least
no but I mean in some sense yeah you
know
okay
great so maybe I I wanted Epson is
smaller than 0.1 just so that it's
compatible with this 0.9 here but um
moving like a convention sort of a
problem that you can't solve is maybe
automatically end here at least
and
so that's a conjecture and yeah just to
get some some intuition about it um what
this problem so what happens if Epsilon
is equal to zero so that's
um that's not considered by the
conjecture but it's an interesting case
to look at so then it means that you can
you know the exists of solution
assessment all of the constraints and
but in that case you know just by some
kind of
a thousand relation or some propagating
these constraints you can find a
solution that satisfies all of the
constraints so that's that's easy
similarly so if uh if K is small let's
say k is equal to two it turns out that
this problem is essentially like uh like
Max cut because
um
you know the constraint either and then
you know C can be either let's say zero
of one and then the constraint either
says that distribution assign the same
level different labels uh to the
to the variables and um and that's
that's essentially uh next step in
particular the algorithm that we
mentioned that I mentioned already saw
in the last lecture you know this is
they find that it would find in this if
it is promise it would find a solution
and satisfies one minus root Epsilon of
equations you know which is which is
bigger than 0.9 for the kind of Epsilon
that we are interested in
okay
something else okay you know the
negative texture is uh it has you know
really uh um uh you know interesting
implications and so therefore we're
trying to understand uh if this uh if
this contexture is true and what DLC is
is this known for every fixed for this
cake yes uh yes so so in general
um if K is less than
2 to the minus 1 over Epsilon
significantly less than that then you
can solve this problem
yes
essentially by uh by similar algorithm
then uh women's videos okay
but here we are you know years of case
it can can be you know as large as login
and so if n is large enough which is
sort of the kind of thing that you're
interested in for some complexity things
then
the decided to the thing and uh okay
what I want to show
foreign
that solves this problem
in time
something better than two to the N so to
the end we or k to the end of these so
the three different algorithm so it
would solve the problem trying to enter
the Epsilon to the home
so one-third is somewhat of the main of
the
that's important so until they have an
Epson aspect is
a new perseverance part and um
what's uh maybe somewhat sort of how
does it relate to the engagement lecture
it relates a following sense that
many MP hardness
artists proves they would always stand
up
assuming something else it's for
problems
so it wasn't for promise problems or is
that
yeah
I'm asking if they're
um yes
for example yeah if I if you would have
pr3
um three variables per work loss and you
would just try to satisfy and you have
this promise you just try to satisfy
more than uh one over K of the
constraints then for this problem the
hardness proof who is our this kind of
yeah I don't understand that myself
oh this one yeah
um do you say that people approve things
yes it's hardness to resolved for which
they need to have the values of Epsilon
words
yes yes so the assumption is that
you know NP is not a subset of
the temperature
you know the preset you know if you
can't have this kind of algorithm forum
and we have problems
yes sorry
to also stated that this kind of
algorithm rules out many NP Farmers
groups yes yes
so yes so it means these kind of
reductions which are for example you
know getting reductions from from labor
cover which is a typical kind of
hardness reductions or these promise
problems they um
they usually the reason is why they want
these kind of algorithm is that the
reduction runs in linear time
linear time and in that that this
assumption without this kind of model
deduction to learning fixed polynomial
time yes
and um
foreign
techniques the they're also useful for
um
constrainted section in general
especially constraint satisfaction
problems that involve two vehicles
okay now
so we want to use his serial
distributions and um
to solve this problem first okay let's
write this
problem a bit more concisely that Define
let that be the value of assignment X be
the fraction of
equations
satisfied the eggs
and you know then the problem that
you're trying to solve is to maximize
over all possible assignments
the the value of assignment
so that's the optimization problem that
we're trying to solve now one question
is where are the polynomials here so
it would be the last time sort of relied
on
someone talking about polynomials in
terms so here uh this you know at first
it doesn't look like a polynomial but um
turns out that there's sort of a generic
useful transformation to make these
things into into polynomials
foreign
that and express
polynomials in these variables you want
to write value of x as a polynomial yes
yes but not in so yeah
confusing thing is that you shouldn't so
here the numbers one to K uh you
shouldn't think that think of them as
real values but I know so some
uh some some symbolic uh
you know labels or a finite group and so
some of you we won't know
in a
natural way and um so it's a yeah just
write this essay
um
so by this you mean choosing the random
equation from a set of equations that's
right yes so to be average over the over
the over the equations and then we um
we want to hear a function that just
tells us whether the equator in this
particular equation is Satisfied by X or
naught and
if you look at the views so here this
notation means um you know it's one if
this is satisfied zero otherwise
so this is one one way of you know
decomposing this one way of expressing
this function and uh you know you can
think of this here
as um
no
so
um you know
there can only be one term with this one
there's only one C for all equations
yes I guess as soon as someone mentioned
that the
intimacies are allowed to vary but uh
can you actually explain that equation
again what is the expected value what is
the distribution ah so here you know we
when we say you know
distraction of constraints so then you
know the the
um you know the baby measure fractions
is uh so if you give every every uh
equation the same weight
but but yes it's not like uh it's not
like we have an equation for every for
every player so that's a you know a
system of your operations you pick a
random equation
um
and uh so here we just you know measure
what's a fraction um
for what fraction of equations is this
so this can be either zero or one so
this measures for what fraction of
equations this is perfect thanks
this way
yeah and so this gives um
like this is just an example but
so this gives
you know a lot of degree
of degree
for
you know functions
for the kind of functions that you're
looking
in general not just for for this
particular function but we don't know in
general these kind of functions and now
we have a notion of saying this notion
of saying is what means this is a degree
it will mean that it's a degree
polynomial in in this term
so you're going to introduce a lot of
new variables is it going to be x i 1 up
to x i k uh yes so that's uh yeah if you
want to think about this from the
algebraic point of view then those are
the variables that we and they're just
going to be Boolean variables they're
going to live on the hybrid yes that's
right nice uh
it itself
you know cumbersome to keep track of
them and like in some sense you don't
need to keep track of them you will
mostly work with the you know work with
functions
of this form and um which is which is
sort of the kind of thing you know
which is which is which is the kind of
thing that we want to maximize
um you only allow Boolean variables for
X but you will but now you're thinking
about this as a real value economy
yeah the values are already
with degree log n and binomials we could
have just enforced uh that are that are
variable x i instead of choosing xia
takes values in the set of one k
why did why did we why did we change
variables but like we could have because
we're only shooting percent explanation
time anyway right so we could have
um
you know a degree K polynomial will let
us the force fit okay
so okay
then we could just take the variables x
i yes but now I mean so
um
this is nicer so we you know you'll
always I mean this this uh this extra
air variables they will not appear ever
again
okay so it's just uh so this is just to
explain what it means when we say that
this kind of a function has degree tool
or degree
it means that you can express this
function as a degree deep polynomial in
these variables
but but we will not have to deal with
them explicitly and so it means that we
will always have you know we can always
deal with functions of this of this form
and so this is this is just a way of
specifying these functions right if if I
tell you you know if I ask if you talk
about the function of this form then um
you know I don't want to think about it
as a as a k to the n-dimensional vector
with the real value for every okay to
the end choices I want to be able to
represent it in a concise way and the
way we represent a function with these
kind of functions in a concise way is as
a polynomial in in these terms
so let's just talk over here
you know where we we will represent
things sufficiently
okay now okay so this is uh so now we
know we have now we see that this is
inside you can think of it as a problem
of maximizing a polynomial and um
and and so that will uh
will allow us you know to if we will
give us the
you're also refined by the student
distribution means in this case
so it's some function
B uh
degree d
so it's a it's a function D on
on assignments
if it's um
you know we will you know represent it
as a liquidity
in in the same sense yes in the same
sentences
and now we want properties of this and
what are the properties that we want so
again we have this notation to
you know to to work with this
this function
it corresponds to which is the same as
you know
is an analog of the expectation of the
of the function and this you know it
will be defined for every uh reloaded
function on this set and so the
conditions that we want about D is that
it should be normalized and this means
that you know if you put plug into the
one function it just means that we sum
up all the values then we want to get up
the bond if it's something that you know
a distribution satisfies so we want a
distribution to satisfy this and
another property that we wanted that
people are enforce is that
if you look at the function that is a
square of um of a
b over 2 polynomial then this should be
then this this expression should be no
negative this is negative
so this is for all the polynomials P the
decrease
over two
and now so this
the distribution over
over our set of assignments and now we
want to
um
you want to do is you know
you're going to use the knowledge that
we you know we we are interested in
these in these solutions that satisfy
our constraints
and how how can we how can we enforce
that you
uh so you can express this in the
following way
yes do you want
maybe you want to think of d as a
moments of a distribution because
sort of a natural to expect distribution
itself to be loadingly
because uh yeah but yes yeah you
shouldn't think about
you shouldn't yeah you shouldn't think
of
maybe think of
um
the low degree part of the distribution
so there's some actual distribution that
you have in mind and uh and we are
looking at the low degree part of that
distribution but I mean does there have
to be distribution
give these
I mean eventually you will be optimizing
or something yes yeah no no there
doesn't have to be a distribution
with these moments but um but the
moments will satisfy all the properties
that you expect moments to satisfy and
the goal will be to show that it's
enough uh that they satisfy these
properties in order to find a solution
but this is the definition of a serial
distribution uh yes I would agree yes
and what you're writing next is is
extra stuff
so here this this one I mean so far this
this one here okay these two these two
conditions
just you know uh correspond to saying
that we have a distribution over
um
over this set
over the set of assignments
and all we want to say that those
assignments satisfy your constraints
this is his title of constraint this guy
you know the constraints of our
function yes yes that satisfies the
first two properties right actually
no no actually it needs more
the probability of any low degree Junta
event or something should be
non-negative and that you can express as
a low degree polynomial yes
so you're saying it
is the distribution of the lady is some
real function
and Define over in keto then such that
it's uh
this is your respiration of one
is one and this is the expectation of
the square of a primary atmosity over 2
is
and also that they should expectation of
a monomials the
is equal to instructional no no no no no
there's no there's no actual uh
distribution so after the second to last
line that's the definition of a suitable
expectation I mean so there's a
difference between sort of
uh I mean
so if you um
or put Solutions
with Solutions in the sense of our
promise okay uh
I mean so usually
in this relaxation that will be the
primer
because you're trying to
it's like the Dual of an sdp I mean I
don't know essentially distribution I
mean distribution says you know given
any non-negative function you get a
non-negative output right but but then
he's saying this is too much so you know
maybe this is too much to guarantee so
let me guarantee that just if you give
me a square which is an obviously not
negative function I'm going to hit on
that negative output and these are
pseudo distributions because I don't
guarantee that for every non-negative
function I get a non-negative Arc we
just put a b squared so I mean in this
case if you know if it would choose a
degree to be and
then uh you know would capture every
function and and yeah maybe maybe that's
a good exercise if you choose the degree
at a degree B here to be n then
the first two conditions just say that
we have a distribution over over the
sign of assignments and this the second
condition this this this condition here
would enforce that it's a distribution
over assignments that satisfy a one
minus Epsilon fraction of the
constraints and now what we are doing to
make you think these things efficient is
trusted with
you know we don't enforce these things
for every every degree but only for
decree up to some
maybe constant or a smaller number
what is p in the left line ah guys
that's a degree degree a polynomial of
degree at most I think D minus two so I
just want to make sure that
like all the things that we are
evaluating here are the three
people in numbers
so the distributions are just another
name for the moment sequences of Placer
that the industry yes yes sir yes yes
it's just yeah it says that like the
uh
it's a different way of operating with
those things and um but the thing is
that if I mean
usually if you talk about moment
sequences then you specify the moments
in a particular basis and usually the
monomial basis and uh and that makes uh
manipulating those those things
cumbersome and so here we we do it in a
way that is independent of a particular
choice of the basis like an equivalent
representation yes
I mean
yeah I'm not I'm not uh giving
references in the in the maybe a way I
should so um yeah this is you know this
this idea of uh enforcing this condition
of just over squares is due to
immigration here
you know the fact that you can do this
efficiently is comes from Shore and
was later as a
cash out a parallel
than the last thing
a very similar idea of feeling you know
when you take a look like
the moment problem when you see yeah
yes
so so your last constraint as soon as
that
um exactly yeah yeah it's just just to
make things a little bit simpler again
yeah so this yeah this model is uh yeah
we would have here arbitrary components
of degree and then this would say that
we have a distribution of our solutions
that have value that satisfy exactly a
one minus Epsilon fraction of difference
so this this is indicated by the degree
of the polynomial
okay so this is and and the the yeah
what what what what what what these
people show is that you can compute this
um
this facility solution here in time
polynomial you know into the time into
the already
today yesterday when you were telling us
about the Boolean case as opposed to
this yes
so that it was clear that once you
Computing time enter the the
greedy part of your functioning big deal
then you can compute that function
completely everywhere because that's
just like the
those are the Fourier coefficients
but um and that
so if you're given just this degree
Little D uh the quotations and the
function big deal that you can Define
this way will satisfy with the pseudo
expression for stress because the higher
degree terms will cancel out
but now it's a bit less clear what's
going on because this degree Little D
terms that you get out of solving the
necessary relaxation
they're not the
Fourier coefficients of this function a
big day
if you look at the cubes
yeah I mean so this is
you know the dysphoria kind of
decompositions it also works for for
General kind of product uh
private spaces like you know K to the
end
but doesn't everything here is secretly
Boolean anyway uh so so yeah no not not
really because like here is there's I
mean There's a constraint that I'm that
I'm not uh I don't want to talk about
explicitly
if you just have the variables xia then
you would have to have the additional
constraint that uh you know only one of
them is one
and all others are zero
right because um I I wanted to be like
an assignment like it should correspond
to an assignment and if you look at
these things then you know the
indicators of uh of these these events
then if you look at a particular
variable x sub I this is only one you
know this is one exactly for one of
those
and so that would be some constraint
that you would have to enforce uh uh you
know uh explicitly if you would talk
about polynomials in X I A just just
about going on with the next study but
here because we talk about functions on
on this set here
um you don't have to deal with these
things existing
it's it's all it's sort of inbuilt
because we talk about these functions
and this is so
yeah so this is the object that we are
getting
and um and you see that you know if you
would choose the green D here to be uh n
then this would um
this would be a actual distribution
but if you choose you know degree to be
very large then it's hard to compute and
uh if you restricted leak but if you
respect liquid it becomes easier to
compute
another goal is to you know
just use the info just use the
information that we get
if you enforce these conditions are
pretty green here and in order to find a
solution
this condition
and
so we will
distribution and now you're able to use
it to find a good solution for the
instance and we will use the for you
know following two um properties that
are used in general and the first
property is that you can condition uh
certain Solutions
and you know conditioning is
it's just if you first think about it
just in terms of uh distributions
there's some random variable in the
testing or distribute in a certain way
and now you know you create a new
distribution
by let's say conditioning the ith
coordinate of the random variable to V8
okay so here I'm thinking of a
distribution over over assignments so
distribution over what is this
not just a you know just what what does
conditioning mean
this kind of distribution and now I
condition it in a condition on the event
it's just a basically some notation
you mean you go from D to D condition
yes yes right so now we have some some
serial distribution D and we want to go
to um
that corresponds to this and um
you know you can Define it exactly in
the way that you would Define it for
distributions
you know basically you you know you zero
out
is there how to function when X exercise
different from a to Let's multiply this
function by this and now you you know
you renormalize
and the way we normalize it is by the
probability that this event tests and
this is uh
corresponds to corresponds to this so
you know if if d a would be an actual
distribution it would be non-negative a
non-negative function then then this
operation here is exactly
conditioning on the event that x i is
equal to a and
you know we can we can do the same
transformation for two distributions is
it obvious that you don't increase
uh yes so exactly that's what we want to
what we want to verify so if the
question is if you have a degree in d uh
distribution here
what what do we get out of it right yeah
so the claim is that this year is a
degree uh let's say D minus two
distribution
you know meaning meaning it satisfies
all of these conditions
um
just uh with the you know a smaller but
okay
necessarily drop
um
this room might not participate in all
yeah you could get lucky um but um in
some sense yeah we sort of
maybe we worry about uh you know we want
to say that in general it never
decreases by by more than two
ah um no I don't know I don't think so
yeah probably not I mean if you know if
if this year would be an actual
distribution then this it would still be
an actual Institution
and so the so the reason why this is
whether it's the case is because
we want to
um
we want to say that if if if for this
new object I only you know
and I'll take you know polynomials P
that are that have a little bit smaller
degree then then we'll still satisfy
these these conditions
okay and and the reason why that's still
the case is because what we multiplied
with here
this is um
uh this is just uh you know this is just
another polynomial and it's called this
actually polynomial that has
um
that's a small degree you know just just
this year as a function on the on the
set it has you know the polynomial that
has degree one and
okay so it means that um
if we
you know if we evaluate the pseudo
expectation of some functional with
respect to D Prime it's like evaluating
the pseudo expectation under D but of
the polynomial
you know uh
multiplied by this here
okay and but but multiplying by this
here can can increase the degree only by
one and okay and the reason why why we
might notice two here
um
for the degrees just because
um you know when you talk about squares
here then um
we need to treat here we need to treat
this here so we need to treat this here
as a square of a of a linear um
uh industry to see as a square and this
is
you know so so this is the same as
just because this takes only value zero
and one this is the same as
you know at this point normally which is
equally true just imagine yeah
everything that's a degree
version is also a degree
that's right
and so you know multiplying by this year
it um
uh
okay maybe it's just uh write it down
you know
just be
look at uh
this kind of expression then this is the
same as
and so normalization here forces you
know to make sure that this year stays
satisfied and the fact that we
multiplied here only by a square means
that all these all these non-activity
constraints and these these conditions
they all satisfied that wasn't satisfied
and this is in some sense um
you know an advantage of having here
this inequalities so
it means that no matter what we
condition on
um we will always you will always you
know it will always be said this this
condition here will will still be
satisfied just maybe with a smaller
equity
but really I mean
so yes so just to verify what your claim
is that this is a degree of the police
deal D minus two yes
degree a degree D minus two sort of
distribution
and um okay so this is this is some uh
some operation that we can we can do
um
another another fact that is useful
about these two distributions is uh that
um
distributions
are are actual distributions
in the for instance so if we you know
just what what does marginal means that
you have some distribution for random
variable X we can look at you know the
distribution just about let's say two of
the coordinates
Exon XJ
and we can do the same thing
um
the same operation to assume
distribution
distribution over two um over you know
two coordinates
in this way and the claim is that you
know
this year is a
you know at least let's say a degree I
don't know four a single distribution
then
then this year uh is actual distribution
okay and this is also something that um
because we've interpreted these to be
between polynomials over the course this
variables x sub IA even the family of
all variables
[Music]
an assignment for two vertices
I and J and so you can you know assign a
so a is what they assigned to i b is
what we say
so what you're really saying is that if
you look at D and you look at any pair
yes of coordinates that induces an
actual distribution on the values
and it's you know an objection
yes yes
and this is
um
you know so it's enough and the only
thing that verifies that this year is
not negative
um uh for all choices of A and B and the
reason why they're so negative is
because you know this here is the same
as
the expectation of the you know the
indicator of this event
and this this event here is um it's a
it's a it's a polynomial of uh it's
actually a square of a polynomial of
degree
doesn't doesn't change it uh so this
here is the square of a degree 2.0 mil
and therefore uh you know by
by this condition they enforced uh it's
not negative
yeah so that means that all a choice of
A and B this is a non-negative number
and you can also check that it sensor to
one
so that means that it's a recipe
now
okay so we have these two properties and
the question is okay what what can be
used for
and the idea is that um
we can use conditioning
um in order to create a new cell
distribution where the variables are
uncorrelated
okay so you can force
the variables
to be uncorrelated
on average
and so what what does it mean uh
precisely that means that if we have a
series of degree D that satisfies these
properties then
we claim that they exists a degree um
e minus
two times r
2 distribution
that satisfies
where the where the variables are
imported or never
okay so it means that if it pick two
random variables a two recruit two two
variables
you pick two of the variables in random
and we look at the correlation between
them what's R uh R is a parameter that
you can choose whatever you like
because for every R this is true second
could be zero zero uh yes but then the
liquidation will not be uh will not be
interesting oh then it will appears
somewhere yes as well
so usually usually it's actually a few
more than once uh yeah
all right so this is it yes this is less
than gamma which is this
divided by r
it's for every r
he claimed that
um
they exists are different D minus two r
as in distribution where the variables
aren't correlated in this sense
and I stands yes that's a good question
so this this here is the dimensional
information okay
between x i and X straight
so maybe
then we think it's more precise so this
is with respect to some distribution
some serial distribution this unit
should be private
um and the future information
with respect to you know some
distribution D two parables
is uh the the amount by which the
entropy drops if you condition one
variable
on the other mirror
distribution yes that's a very good
question uh so can you answer it
distributions are actual distributions
so it means that uh like you know we're
always talking about just you know the
trans distribution of you know these
these things they only depend on the
marginal distribution of these variables
and so it means you know everything is
um will be defined just
just like for actual distributions
[Music]
I'm sorry what's what's the relationship
between DND DND plan is yes that's good
uh I forgot to write that here so this D
Prime is um
uh in this conditioning
uh of uh
obtain D Prime by conditioning
the uh this way
okay so what's the
problem
so then in the proof it actually um you
know it will it may not be about
external situations it may just be about
uh distributions because you only talk
about
um
marginals of almost two guys and
so the group is
that people use as a potential
um
the average entropy of the variable
with respect to uh to some solicitors
and notice also that here that after the
this this expectation sign and this
expectation sign is not with respect to
it's not a zero expectation it's just
choosing these guys and just choosing
variables at random
and people is we use this as a potential
and this is the following procedure
um
you know sort of greedily
condition
on
one event
of the form you know x i is equal to a
you know this is such that
this is
[Music]
actually the distribution that such as
the potential
decreases the most
okay and the claim is that if you follow
this procedure then you will arrive at
uh eventually you will get a solution to
satisfy these properties
um
what why is this the case
so so so so let's look at the what
happens if your condition on a
on a random event
sorry um
on this event uh x i is equal to a you
know for random
I and a
so then
the the decrease in the potential
and expect to decrease in the potential
what do you mean by that by the way
random according to work distribution
yes that's a that's a good question I
was hoping no one notices so um
so it's a random J uh just means a
random variable okay and then uh you
know beautiful
um
uniform years and a random I means um
from the marginal distribution of
of the variable x sub line
yes yes
so you take a index J uniformly at
random and we pick a from the marginal
distribution of the variable x-ray
so even two different ways of choosing
uh I and a what is three related
so yeah so sorry the I'm using J to
condition and
and I to measure the potential I guess
he wants to show them
and so this is the expected potential to
drop if you do this randomly and uh
if you were uh if you look at the the
definition of the this uh this uh
information then it's the same as the
the average Mutual information
and so it means that if you would
condition right on a sort of on this
kind of event for for this random choice
of J and a then um
you know the expected decreases at least
that much if it will clearly it will
increase at least that much and um
and then you know this potentially is
always more negative initially it's it's
almost okay and so it means that you
know this can happen at most
um
you know the the degrees this quantity
is larger than
um Locale over R can happen at most
our practice
which gives you uh this this this this
so we have to condition it most our
times to get to a point where this year
is small
so the question is um suppose now if you
have a similar distribution that
satisfies you know where the variables
are uncorded and average question is
what does it
um
how does it help
and um there are several ways in which
in which it helps
for example
um
what you can show is that if if you had
a
uh if your CSP instance was pseudorandom
so the you know the instance of the CSP
that you're trying to solve
which I think I erase if it was a
pseudo-random in a somewhat big sense it
turns out that this condition here
if you satisfy this condition then it
will always also be the case that
basically all the variables are fixed
it will mean that all the variables are
fixed and then you know you can just
read off an assignment
okay because because it enforce this
condition and you know satisfied it
means that this assignment is satisfied
at the last track you know a very good
fraction of the constraints
but if but even and for any games even
if um
if it's not a even if it's a worst case
instance you can still uh
uh you know it's still useful to have
this kind of condition and
the reason why this is useful is because
um
because you know that four edges if if
this here is a constraint
and you know that's that is satisfied
with um
with the large probability which is
which is the case for for most of the
constraints then it has to be the case
that
um
either either these these variables are
fixed or the music or the mutual um
information is very large
okay so it means that
in the case where the variables are not
fixed or any games it means that on on
edges or edges like the the the mutual
information has to be very large and so
it means that
if you look at the mutual information on
for diff for for random pairs it's much
smaller compared to the mutual
information for
for uh between between variables that
have that that appear in the constraint
together in the equation together
and that means that uh this this graph
that is formed by
the by the equations it uh it turns out
that this means that it's that the
random wall on this graph misses very
slowly and it means that you can
partition the graph into small pieces
and recurves
that's the reason why you can use it to
solve worst case instances because so if
not either
in this condition before either you you
can read off an assignment or you can
partition the graph into small pieces
and repost
yes there was a question
one question
okay so I think
so thanks thanks
[Applause]
conversation
[Music]
um
foreign